[Music]
you
surgical removal of the tumor is part of
the treatment for the majority of breast
cancers there are a number of surgical
options your doctor will help you decide
which is best for your situation in
addition to surgery on the breast it may
be necessary to remove some or all of
the lymph nodes under your arm
there are two main surgical procedures
for breast cancer the first is breast
conserving surgery or lumpectomy which
is always coupled with radiation
treatment
the second is mastectomy which is
removal of the entire breast it may be
combined with breast reconstruction
surgery in both procedures it may be
necessary to remove some lymph nodes
a lumpectomy preserves the appearance of
the breast the tumour along with a
margin of surrounding normal breast
tissue is removed in this procedure your
surgeon will make an incision in the
skin
and remove the tumor with a margin of
healthy tissue it will be sent to a
pathologist for examination to make sure
there is no cancer in the surrounding
margin of tissue the wound will be
closed with sutures
in a mastectomy the entire breast is
removed in a simple mastectomy only the
breast tissue is removed your surgeon
will begin by making an incision to
remove an oval of skin including the
nipple the breast tissue will be
separated from the skin as well as the
underlying muscle and removed for
examination finally your surgeon will
insert drains to prevent fluid
collection a modified radical mastectomy
is a procedure where your breast tissue
is removed along with some or all of the
lymph nodes under your arm
a sentinel lymph node biopsy is
typically performed in addition to a
lumpectomy or a mastectomy it may be
done if a clinical exam or imaging study
shows no evidence that cancer has spread
to the lymph nodes the purpose of the
biopsy is to identify and check the
first draining lymph nodes from the
breast to make sure cancer hasn't spread
there to do this dye will be injected
into your breast to determine which
lymph nodes are the sentinel lymph nodes
your surgeon will remove one two three
sentinel lymph nodes for examination if
these nodes have no cancer it is
unlikely other lymph nodes have cancer
if these lymph nodes have cancer the
rest of the lymph nodes under your arm
called axillary lymph nodes may also
have cancer in this case a complete
axillary lymph node dissection may be
recommended to remove most of the nodes
in this area
an additional option in the case of a
mastectomy is reconstruction of the
removed breast breast reconstruction
makes use of implants or tissue from
other parts of the body such as the
abdomen or buttocks to create a new
breast in some cases the surgeon is able
to also preserve the nipple the
reconstruction can be performed right
after a mastectomy known as immediate
reconstruction
or at a later date called delayed
reconstruction if you are considering
reconstructive surgery your doctor can
help you decide what approach is best
for your situation